[Musica]
sono un caccia
un cacciatore di dettagli e mi occupo di
infanzia i migliori calciatori di i
dettagli sono i bambini sanno giocare
con una goccia di rugiada sotto una
foglia sanno giocare con la polvere che
attraversa un raggio di sole sono
cacciatori di dettagli loro io ci provo
però ho un sasso nella scarpa
eppure nei posti che frequento i
cosiddetti luoghi educativi non hanno
sassi pochissimi sono oggetti proibiti
pericolosi anche i sassolini sono
oggetti cose in via di estinzione ma i
bambini non sanno trovare lo stesso se
non solo in superficie scout scavano
scavano a volte trovano delle cose che
ti vengono a dire guarda un osso di
dinosauro
ma il sasso resta pur sempre qualcosa da
non toccare i bambini lo sanno se lo
trovano sanno che più o meno fossero
fare due cose o lo lasciano la o lo
consegnano all'adulto poi c'è quello che
cerca la terza via la terza strada e
arriva con gli occhi pieni di luce un
sorriso smagliante ti guarda e ti dici
guarda
ho trovato un sasso a forma di cuore e
l'adulto di fronte a un sasso a forma di
cuore non può dir di no non ce la fa
i bambini sanno quali sono i nostri
punti deboli i bambini sanno come
convincerci comunque sia il sasso se non
è a forma di cuore lo si tocca perché è
così difficile giocare oggi con un
sassolino
perché è così difficile oggi giocare con
niente certo uno sarebbe successo il
sasso c'è anche il bastone tra gli
oggetti che creano allarme quando un
bambino di tocca però il sasso se la
gioca bene col bastone ma il sasso fa
più impressione perché quando viene
lanciato si può nascondere la mano e
allora cosa succede succede che di
fronte a un sassolino fosse fermano a
tutti
eppure c'è qualcosa che ci distrae un po
sono i timori del nostro tempo che ci
allontanano dalle cosiddette attrazioni
naturali e un po alla fretta che ci
distoglie dai dettagli ludici ma i
bambini i dettagli e ludici ricercano
provate a pensare se avete accompagnato
un bambino ai giardini pubblici per noi
il gioco e la ai giardini pubblici cioè
l'altalena scivolino e allora via col
bambino mano nella mano andare a
giardini e che fa il bambino vede uno
scalino ci sale sopra
certo lo vedo un buco nel muro ci mette
il dito vede un fiorellino e cresce sul
cemento a quel punto lì da dove
si sofferma un po di più vede il sasso è
no potrebbe cascarci rimbalzare per
terra a finirli sul lato feriti dai
denti e se c'è la vetrina potrebbe anche
romperla
e allora i bambini si insegnano la cosa
è molto importante
il cammino che si fa i passi che
cerchiamo di fare incontrando anche
sassi per un adulto è più importante la
meta al giardino dei bambini è più
importante il cammino è difficile stare
al passo dei bambini dettagli dettagli
ludici eppure il sasso nei giochi
popolari ne troviamo lo troviamo come
grande protagonista
sicuramente fra di voi qualcuno ci gioca
ancora sicuramente qualcuno fa di voi
gioca a quel gioco dove il sasso lo
lancia in modo tale che calcola il più
possibile la cosiddetta tensione
superficiale la tensione superficiale
quella cosa e quando vai ti tuffi
nell'acqua se non entri per così mentre
per così dire la manciata rimbalzello e
quel gioco dove il sasso deve rimbalzare
sulla superficie dell'acqua del mare
se carlo di un fiume di un lago in o ne
giocavano alle cinque pietre
forse qualcuno l'ha visto sono cinque
sassolini per terra se ne prende uno si
lancia bellaria mentre uno e bellaria
bisogna prenderne un altro malato sta
accendendo allora velocemente bisogna
prendere le vicende e venne 2 e poi 345
abilità raffinatissimi utili anche per
fare
che cosa per muovere la mano per
scrivere per fare tutte queste cose qua
dalle mie parti che abita nel chianti si
gioca a small iella una specie di gioco
con le bocce che si fa con dei ciottoli
si lancia il ciottolo vicino a un ciocco
lino o sassolino è che il più vicino fa
più punto ma la cosa bella è questo
gioco e che bisognava colpire il
ciottolo di quell'altro in modo che
quell'altro se competeva e il nostro
rimaneva intero e lì di nuovo portante
sassolini per inventare nuovi giochi
insomma tanti sassolini per inventare
nuovi giochi
il sasso il gioco più famoso più
conosciuto diciamo così col sasso e la
campana o la settimana qualcuno la
chiama riga qualcuno la chiama mondo è
diffuso in tutte le culture moltissime
culture ed esiste dalla notte dei tempi
so che a cesena la chiamate smena detto
bene tu provato
sven pensate alla sme la cosa vi viene
in mente se pensate alla sme la
l'immagine della sme la zucca dell'asm e
la avete sicuramente pensato al sasso
non sto parlando d'altro
mi che avete pensato del sal tellino
quello così no avete pensato al sasso
voi sapete bene che nel sasso si
riconosce il dettaglio la profondità di
questo gioco
certo è il gioco consiste nel saltare su
un piede allargare le gambe ma nel sasso
si entra nel profondo col sasso senza il
profondo perché la prima cosa da fare è
andata a cercare ed ecco che cercare il
sasso significa perlustrare lo spazio
intorno a noi farci delle mappe intorno
a noi e chiedersi ma dove li hanno
nascosti questi sassi questi adulti
competenze scientifiche e antropologiche
soprattutto se poi il sasso che ci serve
quello che deve scrivere ricordate
quanto era importante per il salso
descrive era un tesoro prezioso da
tenere in tasca il sasso descrive lascia
il segno soprattutto nella nostra
crescita
perché perché se io o disegno la campana
o la settimana all us me la devo vedere
quanto fa la grande sala faccia troppo
grande non ci riesco se la faccio troppo
piccola non c'entra la faccio media non
mi sfido abbastanza se poi gioco con un
altro devo trovare una giusta misura
se gioco con me stesso devo misurare le
mie capacità con le mie ambizioni se
gioca con l'altro devo misurare le mie
capacità con quello dell'altro in modo
che la sfida possa avere un senso
questo si chiama anche fair play ma
soprattutto possiamo cercare di dire
faccio sempre la solita campana o ne
invento una gianfranco staccioli
pedagogista del gioco a fare voli in
italia
ho fatto una ricerca che ci fa vedere
che nel mondo
le campane sono a forma di serpente le
chiocciole a pallone a ballini con le
lettere a forme irregolari
e allora ecco nuovi orizzonti con che
cosa con un dettaglio il sassolino
questo principio vale in tutti i giorni
ora siamo a carnevale
e pensate al carnevale
come posso vestire con un mantello di un
supereroe
metti che c'è un mantello di zorro po
come quello che avevo da bambino il
mantello di zorro mi chiede di giocare
mi induce a giocare soprattutto azzurro
ma se ho un progetto ludico non ancora
identificato
che cosa succede succede per esempio che
con un foulard lo faccio zorro
non ho niente contro il giustiziere
mascherato posso fare il motorino posso
fare quello che gioca al cameriere posso
fare
l'elicottero c'è una sostanziale
differenza fra le costruzioni
preconfezionate che già ti dicono che
cosa costruire e un legnetto d'olivo in
questo periodo si inizia a potare gli
olivi un legnetto d'olivo irregolare
sbilenco che neanche sta in piedi
imperfetto il gioco è imperfetto ha
bisogno delle imperfezioni
pensate ai bambini quando giocano dicono
se faccia io ero che tu facevi il gioco
deve essere imperfetto in un mondo di ad
altissima definizione misurarsi con le
inevitabili imperfezioni della vita
offre occasione di crescita fondamentali
la biglia levigatissima l'antenata della
migliara alla noce la biglia se la legge
con la scacchiera grossomodo va dove voi
la voce anche se fa la migliore
schicchera del mondo all'inizio va dove
voi quante la curva strana
eccoci di nuovo a un oggetto di gioco
che ci mette di fronte un'altra sfida
all'altra da un altro modo di prendere
le misure con la realtà con
l'imprevedibile con l'inatteso in una
situazione in cui si pensa è tutto possa
essere controllabile ecco che oggetti
come questo ci offrono la possibilità di
misurarsi anche con l'inaspettato
insomma cosa vi voglio dire vi voglio
dire che con questo tipo di attenzione
con la cura del dettaglio ludico che
cosa si può fare
si può aumentare il pil
l'avete capito bene il pil intanto
sicuramente il prodotto interno ludico
fatto di poesia di bellezza di gioco ma
anche il prodotto interno lordo ekman
primo nobile della co dell'economia ci
dice con i suoi studi quanto sia
importante investire in educazione
investire nella qualità del gioco e
investire sull'educazione incide anche
sulla crescita del pil prodotto interno
lordo sulla crescita economica
in questo caso sarebbe un pil che non
tiene conto solo dei numeri ma anche del
benessere della persona e della felicità
o e tutto questo perché con oggetti di
questo tipo si attiva un pensiero un
fare divertente e divergente con un
foulard un legno sbilenco d'olivo e
delle voci che cosa si attiva si pone le
basi a qualcosa si può che ci aiuta a
reinventarci il presente
già proprio così porre le basi per
inventarci è presente a partire dal
divertimento e della divergenza
divertimento e divergenza hanno la
stessa radice etimologica e con il sasso
con il sasso io me lo sono tolto dalla
scarpa
ve lo lancia il vostro gioco e non
nascondo le mani
[Applauso]
grazie